okay so his elbow is going to be the
point that i want
i don't want to shove his elbow
backwards
there is a place where his elbow is
going to end and that's where i want to
be
i don't know what the foot maneuvers are
he decides okay okay but this is going
to be wrong
and any version of that is going to be
wrong so taking his hand back here
that's all young young you see he's
going that way you have to let his young
energy
uh be able to right
with your young energy so you can't go
while he's in young
and then you round back
so his energy just comes into my back
and believe it or not it's not a matter
of whether you pay
you fake
[Music]
don't think of it
purely spatially okay
so you don't even pay attention but
that's not an athletic foot
okay
you have to have the midfoot
that ankle has to be over the heel can't
be with a caved arch boom
okay and she's she's running into
that round vector
you're attaching
just work on the elbow
so even if my foot is forward
it's still that
i'm just not sweeping her stance
okay
don't start a bracing angle especially
one so inferior okay
yeah
okay so
uh
there's only
these kazushi patterns right front
inward
back inward
back inward back outward okay
so
they're always on a body tail you can
stand square
they're not going straight back
they're always on a body tail they're
always on a tilt
so here i'm i'm making his body go that
angle
not this angle
okay so that's the first thing i know
he's on a tilt then the second thing is
in aikido
he always goes around me i'm always the
center of the of the
tactical geometry right so if i was here
right and he has to go around me
then i have to enter
over there
entering over here he goes parallel to
me
entering straight in
he doesn't go around me
i have to go this this way chill for you
can hold on to me okay lean
he has to go this way
[Music]
therefore the id me is over here
not strange
and not in the direction he was
remember i swept her leg at higher
levels while her leg is to the inside of
me
okay the leg is this one
also if you look at what's called
shikaku's
[Music]
the dead angle
is where he has no base of support
okay
and if that's what i'm dropping then i
drop that
where his dead angle
no that's gonna be that way
you need to make an x with the line of
attack okay you have to make a cross
it's diagonal
the problem
or the question you're asking is is
there a place where his elbow is going
either forward nor backwards where it
becomes easy to manipulate
into this
so that his ongoing energy
makes his
line of gravity fall outside his face
support that that is the technique okay
the technique is not over here
not the technique
you're working well let's call that the
sweet spot the wu-wei spot i don't have
to do anything it does it okay
so
as part of that wu-wei spot the length
of my arms
don't lengthen or shorten to get it it's
impossible now
you see you're either too far too close
so the length of your arm stays the same
that's what he hits
you get it
so that's part of the technique
one length okay not
bending also not extending okay
try it
so that sweet spot
doesn't change even if i if i throw a
strike i have to make sure
that i don't lengthen my arms
or bend my arms
it's not a matter again of space it's a
matter of timing okay
figure it out
you're coming in and stopping
come in
do your job
okay
there is an important point to make
about the way elbow
if you're feeling powerful
that's not it
subjectively you feel powerful because
you feel your muscles
overcoming the resistance but that's
big man on keto okay
so again there is a sweet spot where
that elbow
doesn't take any energy do you get it
and that's what you're trying to feel
for okay
well let's put it this way if you feel
yourself overpowering that's not it so
feel for that okay it's not i don't
actually feel for this sweet spot okay
uh
and then the other thing is is that his
energy is going it's going into that
ground path that's actually what i'm
feeling for this this uh
projection okay
so bring your bring your awareness back
to this stuff
get your awareness back on that back
foot
okay so you hide your your cool cue
element
well you have your ikea element too
so if you're not here and
stressing these things
it's here
oh
you guys here i'm not grabbing it okay
you're going to create an adhesion
this version pops out past
okay let's try that version to emphasize
even though he's grabbing me
and i'm touching his arm it's an
adhesion it's not a external pull and
grab okay
try that version
so i have my cue i have my eye key i
have my my so uh let's play with it okay
so i'll do my attempt
and if he uh carries it this way
then you'll take this one
again you'll carry it to the inside wall
right
who is deciding what to do
so
what's on this one see i let him go
you kind of let the cross rotate you see
so we'll do that one again we got way
possible
i think this one you understand
on the parry like he's carrying it
through the elbow but the other one
again he's counted to the elbow but i am
just doing this adhesion
down there that doesn't really change
when he goes to the inside right
it's not that he's uh make it stronger
it's not that he's stopping me you don't
worry about it that's just your
connection point
do you see how i did that okay this is
what i always advise the uk i wouldn't
keep my hand up there
because the center of gravity is really
high okay now of course if you're
if your
your nugget doesn't understand this then
you will jack them up but this is this
is still
as much tenshi nugget as the other one
okay
uh let's say they push our way off
he's way out you get it
um
but he did it the right way you should
keep your arm in your outer rim do you
see not pushing it out like this
it is out of rim and there is stretching
okay i always be ready to take you cami
right
here you go